so das ist unser Fragenlotto also kannst
du mich jetzt wieder angucken was ist
das Fragenlotto Fragenlotto so das der
Vorteil ist du kannst die Nieten und die
Gewinnerlose schon erkennen ja die
Nieten sind sind die Grünen nein sind
die roten die Nieten sind unverschämte
Fragen und die Grünen sind total
harmlose fragena du kannst
entscheiden soll ich aufmachen ja
klar
klar geht ihnen die Volksmusik im Grunde
ihres Herzen nicht tierisch auf den
Geist nein also ich stehe dazu es gibt
einfach Dinge in meinem
Leben also wer mich kennt das was ich
mache das dazu stehe ich also ich bin
mit der Volksmusik aufgewachsen und
äh es steckt ja leider immer zu viel von
dieser Musik in irgendwelchen heile Welt
Schubkästen der deutschen dieses
Schubladen
denken das ist teilweise schlimm macht
uns aber eigentlich nichts aus also es
macht uns eigentlich eher in der
Volksmusik Szene noch stärker und nein
ich liebe diese Musik aber ist ist die
Volksmusik an dem heile Welt Image nicht
selber schuld ich meine es geht ja
meistens um positive Dinge und ja gut
wir wollen ja auch nicht hören in in
Sarajevo geht ein Kernkraftwerk in die
Luft ne
da möchte keiner drüber irgendwie singen
ich sag mal pur oder Christina Stürmer
oder egal mr President agulero hat es
glaube ich gesungen ne das sind auch
Dinge wir wünschen uns eine schönere
Welt eine dass unsere unsere Welt nicht
top in Ordnung ist ne da braucht man nur
jeden Tag die Tageschau anmachen aber
man wünscht sich das und natürlich weil
wir das heute
so direkt
verkörpern also jeder schaut auf uns
weil es eben Erfolg ist erfolgreich sind
ist man eben in dieser Schublade drinnen
macht uns aber überhaupt nichts andere
machen es auch über die wird nicht
gesprochen über uns wird gesprochen soll
wir machen gut ja wir haben auch noch
grüne Fragen ja ist
klar wahrscheinlich in S ist das
wahrscheinlich die schlimmeren kommt
immer drauf an für einen sind für den
einen sind sie die schlimmeren für die
anderen das sind halt alles Fragen die
wirürd man normalerweise nicht fragen
gegen sie ist
Hein ja eine Eintagsfliege was ist das
Geheimnis ihres dauerhaften Erfolges
also wenn ich so viele Platten verkauft
hätte und so Kult gewesen wäre wie Heine
also da kann man nur eigentlich ein Hut
vorziehen also der hat glaube ich einer
von wenigen die erfolgreichsten Filme
mit unseren glaube ich erfolgreichsten
Entertainer Europas Peter Alexander
gemacht ich denke nicht dass dieser
Eintagsfliege er kann ja nichts dafür
dass er ein Stimmbruch gehabt hat
M natürlich hab man als Kind immer mehr
Vorteile irgendwo aber dieser Mann hat
einfach in seinem Leben wie er noch
junge war so viel erreicht ich glaube
nicht dass das unter Eintagsfliege zählt
also er singt ja auch heute noch und
er war auch in einer meiner ersten
Sendung also da komm einfach nur den
hutin von diesem Mann ne was der ein
jungen Jahen geschafft hat für das dass
er dann hier aus war kann er nichts für
nee hut ab keine eintagspfliege gut noch
eine rote oder eine grüne ich nehme me
grüne die war ganz
interessant
wie haben Sie es geschafft bis heute
ihren jugendlichen Scham zu behalten so
keine
Ahnung ach ich glaube wenn man das alles
irgendwie zu verbissen sieht
dann ja ich weiß es nicht also ich liebe
es Hal heute irgendwie so zu sein
ne klar spricht man sich immer leichter
wenn man wenn
man wenn man vielleicht Erfolg hat oder
irgendwie also ich weiß ja nicht wenn
wie es wie es wäre wenn man wenn man
keinen Erfolg mehr hat ne das ist ja
auch ganz was schlimmes also ich bin ja
momentan einfach so glücklich dass ich
mit mir selber spielen kann also ich
habe tolle Familie ich habe Erfolg in
meinem
Beruf habe tolle Freunde die mir zur
Seite stehen und dann kann ich auch ganz
anders mit mir also um Gottes Willen ich
bin nicht immer so wie wie vor der
Kamera was kann auch mal rausm
zusammenschlagen ne V later Wut oder ein
Rechner aus dem Fenster schmeißen weil
einfach zum hunderen mal den Scheiß
Virus drauf
hat das ist schon passiert ja ja ganz
schlimm also wenn oh ja D möchte das
Thema möchte nicht we aber aber nee also
aber ich liebe es einfach auch mich
selber mal auf Arm zu nehmen also wer
über sie sich selber nicht lachen kann
der hat eigentlich in dieser Szene
nichts verloren mich hat mal Stefan R
gefragt oder Harald Schmidt macht
eigentlich aus wenn man dich ab und so
mal so verarschen oder so also das ist
ja das genialste dieser Welt also wenn
ich daheim sitze und einer verarscht
mich im Fernsehen ich lach mich dumm und
schäppig und wenn man das nicht mehr
kann dann soll man lieber ins finanzum
gehen und vorm Computer arbeiten und um
8 Uhr in die Arbeit gehen und um 17 Uhr
wieder nach
Hause dann hab man in der
Unterhaltungsszene nichts zu
suchen ja ich glaube ja noch zum
Abschluss gleich eine rote ja nimm
rote so jetzt wä wahrscheinlich war der
Griff in die Kloschüssel wollen
sie wollen sie nicht auch mal gerne gute
Musik
machen die machen wir
eigentlich es ist ja so dass es einfach
Leute gibt das habe ich vorher schon
angesprochen dieses Sch denken die sagen
mein Gott du Rose oder ihr alle da
zusammen jetzt stellen sie mir vor diese
Musik würde es nicht geben und es geht
zum Oktoberfest oder zum
abie und es könnte keiner Mitsingen es
könnte keiner was tun es könnte keiner
auf die Bänke gehen diejenigen die
nämlich sagen was machst du den für eine
scheiß Musik die erwischt man plötzlich
unter der Dusche irgendwo und können
alle Texte können alles Mitsingen ne
also ich verlange nicht von jeden dass
es kufsteinlied in und auswendig kann
das kann ich nicht einmal oder irgendwie
wir singen auch kein kufsteinlied wir
singen auch keinen schneewolzer wir
machen auf der Bühne auch mal Dinge wo
man sagen das möchte ich jetzt mal
ausprobieren also Reinhard Fendrich habe
ich z.B auf meiner letzten CD von ihm
Titel gehabt Stefanie singt auf der
Bühne Lieder von aber man kann so vieles
machen eben weil es diese
Unterhaltungsmusik ist also es ist Musik
fürs Volk und da kann man so viel
ausprobieren also wenn Sie wenn es diese
Musikrichtung nicht mehr geben würde
würde es bisschen ärmlicher ausschauen
auf dieser Welt also erstens es gibt ja
viele Leute die verstehen ja nicht
einmal von ihren Idolen die Texte weil
sie ja gar nicht so Englisch können
teilweise versteht man auch die
englischen Texte gar nicht also drum bin
ich froh dass ich Deutsch
singe super vielen Dank ja danke schön
das war sehr schön ja